the penultimate episode of loki on
disney plus was a
wild variant-filled ride that set up
what is sure to be a mind-blowing finale
it was also jam-packed with fun easter
eggs for fans to find
here are a few you may have missed in
episode 5 journey into mystery
at the beginning of episode 5 we travel
through a destroyed
cityscape full of decrepit buildings
most of these structures
seem like filler to emphasize the
destruction but there's one significant
easter egg hidden within the rubble
that's worth noting
toward the end of the camera pan a
building on the right
reads kang q-e-n-g at the top of it
marvel comics fans should know this
famous name as it's related to a major
villain who's set to appear in the mcu
this tower represents kang enterprises
and if you thought it looked like the
avengers tower you weren't wrong
in the comics it's revealed that stark
industries sold the building to the
company and avengers vol
6 number zero from 2015. the ceo of kang
industries is mr griffin
aka nathaniel richards who exists on
earth 6311
an alternate version of earth 616 the
reality where all the main marvel stuff
goes down
nathaniel richards is also known as king
the conqueror as the latter was split
into two different versions of himself
due to a time stream error it's a
complicated story from 2015's all-new
all different avengers number one but
this nod de kang a major villain we know
will appear in ant-man and the wasp
quantomania
is something that we can't ignore during
episode 5
one of the first things we see in the
void is a menacing purple black
cloud with a monstrous face within it
this is the void that's goliath
where his lungs come on known as a
transtemporal entity
eliath doesn't exist in any reality but
instead what the comics describe as
temporal limbo the being is the biggest
enemy of kang the conqueror
and its empire is bigger than his foes
eliath first appeared in 1993's avengers
the terminatrix objective number one and
is known for its absorption powers which
we saw play a huge role in episode 5.
eliath is drawn to living beings more
than anything and has the power to
disintegrate them as soon as it
encompasses them
in the mcu it appears as if eliatha
lives within the void at the end of time
unlike its location in the comics it's
also being used to protect
the person or entity behind the
timekeepers who many now suspect to be
kang
if this is the case in the mcu the two
would be on the same side
a massive shift from their comic book
origins
in a move we never thought would happen
the thanos copter became canon in the
marvel cinematic universe thanks to loki
episode 5.
when the mad titan finally perished in
avengers end game
it looked like we might never see the
famous aircraft but now we know why we
never did
the thanos copter first appeared in
1979's spidey super stories number 39
and was a helicopter the villain used
one time to attack hellcat
a popular marvel hero who fought the
titan as he tried to obtain the cosmic
cube
thanos also picked up deadpool in the
helicopter in deadpool vol
5 number 45 when the latter was hired to
help the mad titan steal the cube
it's such a shame we never got to see
that scene play out on the big screen
fortunately loki episode 5 paid homage
to a great and
frequently mocked comic book moment the
thanos copter matched its comic book
appearance exactly with its bright
yellow paint and the titan's name
written across it in large bold letters
we knew we'd be getting a version of the
trickster god from the classic vote loki
comic after he appeared in several
trailers for the series
and he finally arrived in episode 5 but
only for a brief scene where a scuffle
breaks out between a gaggle of loki's
as for the variant's origin story the
four-part comic series
debuted in june 2016 and was a satire on
the united states presidential election
of the same year
in the fourth and final issue loki
concedes the race
in the comics loki's campaign is based
on his honesty about how he's going to
lie to the american public
the citizens eat it up except for a
reporter from the daily bugle who's
trying her best to take him down
it's definitely one of the weirdest loki
stories of all time complete with
political action cults sacrificing goats
and we're incredibly glad this dapper
and politically ambitious loki got to
show up on the screen
even if it was only for a few minutes
just before the loki group makes their
way down to their secret hideout we see
different layers of
rubble above their little base and
buried in all this debris
we get a glimpse of mjolnir and a small
glass jar with t365 written on it
trapped inside this jar is a tiny
version of thor
and one who's a bit more amphibious than
we're used to seeing the god of thunder
known as throgg this powerful frog
version of thor first appeared in thor
number 363
although number 365 is more significant
for the character because it's where he
lifted mjolnir and became the thunder
frog officially
this coincides with mjolnir being just
out of throg's reach in the episode as
he's trapped in the glass jar
thor number 365 also heavily features
loki who suspects something is afoot
with his brother
it's a hilarious storyline which
includes thor helping an army of frogs
battle
an army of rats just as with db cooper
in episode 1
episode 5 of loki further explained some
great american mysteries
the first to appear in journey into
mystery was polybius an
arcade game long considered an urban
legend the legend of polybius suggests
this fictitious 80s game was real and
run by the government as a psychological
experiment
it was supposedly created to test mind
control on users but the arcade game was
never
found it looks like it was swooped up by
the tva and sent to the place where
urban legends go to die
in the middle of episode 5 we also see
the uss eldridge fall out of the sky and
into the void unlike polybius the famous
naval ship was an actual thing
in 1943 it was alleged that the ship was
made invisible as part of the famous
philadelphia experiment
as some claim it was also apparently
teleported from philadelphia to
virginia and back again crew members who
were on board reportedly went insane
and the story was so bizarre it was
adapted into a time travel movie the
philadelphia experiment in 1984.
since episode 5 mostly took place in the
void set designers had a major
opportunity to include an incredible
amount of easter eggs from the mcu's
past
some of these include ant-man villain
yellowjackets helmet in the first
act which we saw as we panned over the
landscape and
ronan's dark ouster spaceship also makes
a brief appearance
we also get a brief look at a demolished
telecarrier sitting in the wasteland
also in the vast devastation across loki
episode 5 is what appears to be a stone
face of the living tribunal
which we know isn't an mcu relic yet
one of the most important entities in
marvel comics is the character who first
appeared in strange tales number 157
from 1967.
the living tribunal basically oversees
everything ever
in every reality serving as somewhat of
a judge of the entire cosmic universe
and all of its realities the tribunal is
more powerful than all of the infinity
stones
combined check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one